this is the most mind-blowing wildlife
experience you could ever hope to have
hello and look at that flat cat times
two there so flat they almost merge into
one where with the five Musketeers here
in the eastern sectors of the Maasai
Mara reserve in Kenya this is coming to
you a hundred percent live and my name
is Frank Leo Smith I have Joey on camera
and as I said we've been with these
cheetah for seven and a half hours today
they got us quite excited a little while
ago Jehova know and busy sort of having
a little bit of a nap and then all of a
sudden there is some running and dashing
and all they did is run in - and flat
and go flat again so we're hoping they
are going to go moving again quite soon
the temperature has dropped rapidly
there's a absolute gale today according
to the the wither people which sometimes
lies you on the interwebs it's in
certain parts of the Mara the wind is
over 80 kilometres an hour today I would
say we're probably sitting a good 45 40
45 kilometres an hour winds we've got
our back to the wind so it doesn't
hopefully doesn't affect us too much now
if you want to ask any questions about
said flat cats or any other magical
things that are out here in the African
bush you can do so by using the hashtag
Safari live it'll be great to hear from
you and I'm pretty sure you can hear the
wind
now unfortunately Jamie's had a few
gremlins so she's got off a little late
this afternoon
so you're stuck in the howling gale with
Joey and myself no I mean you look at
the grass doesn't look that match but
remember the grass is so short there
isn't much of it to blow about
no they different as I said we're on the
the sunrise Friday that doesn't look
like they're ate last night all this
morning or if they did it was something
as meager as a scrub hill or a baby
Tommy so certain individuals are looking
quite hungry and I think with this cool
windy weather
they might get up on the move a little
bit earlier this afternoon we played the
patience game with them yesterday and
this morning and no luck maybe third
time's a charm
well I suppose we played the patience
game with them all day today to be
honest and yesterday but it's the third
Drive is what I'm talking about they do
look quite comfortable they marched away
they were sleeping in those crotons up
head just behind them there that's where
they were this morning so you can see
they haven't covered much distance at
all and you can there we can see a bit
of the wind blowing the crotons
now the the wind and the Mara does blow
quite frequently ja how is obviously
spent a lot of time in the end the Mara
over the last few years and is there any
month or season you find particular more
windy than others comes and goes I think
it's just a windy place yeah and
especially you can see that with a very
short grass lack of big trees and only
small bushes and so big trees probably
battle to get big in these areas and
then if we have a look where we do see
the odd big tree apart from the Balan I
tease of course and the tear that seem
to be quite wind resistant the other big
tree is always in a slightly more
protected area just like that I don't
even see that hills and Tanzania in the
background miRs wondering how would the
wind affect the ability to hunt well Mia
it actually wouldn't affect their
ability to hunt at all it would in
enhance their ability that so it would
be very good for them what happened is
that quite often the animals won't even
hear them even when their feet up
pounding as they hit that top speed the
animals won't hear them
also this wind is really strong so they
sent if their walk into the wind is
going to be quite well
now of course a lot of animals rely more
on their eyesight to spot predators but
with this wind it's also gonna make oh
there we go it might affect them a
little bit it will make a lot of the
animals very very nervous when the wind
is blowing like this animals don't like
this wind now speaking of animals there
are no animals around us at the moment
have a quick mother look I've been
checking constantly throughout the
afternoon we had some zebras run past
that made them lift their head but they
looked a bit big adult zebras
nope nothing off to the right to the
left in the distance maybe I see some
creatures they have some topi down on
the valley there but very very far away
and big herds of wildebeest and zebra
but on the other side of the the valley
far away down there near the topi and
they are in there hello topes watch out
this cheater about and then on that far
hill you can see some little dots and
stuff with all the beasts and zebra so
not much Ron there are quite a lot of
animals not too far over the ridges
around us but nothing close by at the
moment these are truly flat cats this
very moment oh I think I've lost comms
again did you get comms there John ah
there we go
well it seems like Jamie's got her
gremlins sorted so while we play the
patience game with the fire boys let's
send you back to the far west north
western corner of the Maasai Mara to see
what's happening in the Triangle
a very good afternoon to all of you and
welcome to the mara triangle portion of
this sunset Safari starting off in a
very very windy afternoon the wind is
howling it's blowing dust everywhere my
name is Jamie and this afternoon Craig
is on camera with me and we've just been
debating whether or not what we're
seeing on the horizon is rain or haze
because it is so windy I think it's a
little bit too thick I think this wind
might be blowing in some kind of front
but we can't even see towards the
mountains in Tanzania and as we're
driving along the wind keeps gusting the
dust back towards us so the plan for the
afternoon is to well be slightly more
successful than we were this morning I
couldn't find anything this morning
except elephants which is I'm never
going to complain about the base of our
mountain is always a good place to start
though we've got a parlor we've got
zebra
and usually the odds of a boon or two a
couple of war togs
let's see what we can find I also want
to try and figure out why that's
neighbors making such a noise
I'm sad that the eland family isn't here
today there is a massive herd of about
thirty odd alerts that live around here
your unexpected so it's not just general
game animals today there's mischief
thank next to the road
see how relaxed it is sometimes the
hyenas around this area are quite
skittish
no no no panic don't panic don't panic
very good to me about the the fluffiness
yesterday was it yesterday Tristan and I
were talking about a scale of fluffiness
one of the viewers actually suggested
what have you guys actually suggested
the depth that your hand would sink into
the fur of the animal as a appropriate
unit of measurement and the reason we
were talking about it is because the
hyenas here in Kenya are that much
fluffier than the one so we got you
scared of zebra that had nothing to do
with us and everything to do with the
zebra this hippo in this area don't taik
nonsense from hyenas and that's because
the hyenas here hunt them they have the
advantage of numbers and so if the zebra
find themselves staring down an
individual excuse me they will chase
them david it's a tricky one you wanted
to know if there are animals that change
their behavior when rain is coming
certainly i think that all animals are
aware as far as sooner than we are when
rain is on its way there are certain
birds that will call when the rain is
coming something like a cuckoo for
example when they pick up the changes in
pressure let me just move out of the way
of this vehicle sorry they pick up on
changes in pressure
and then increase in moisture in the air
you'll see swallows swooping about it's
mostly birds frogs might start to call a
little bit more frequently hi guys how
are you good
hi we are at WWF what are we talking
about animals changing behavior drain
but what you'll find the biggest
behavioral change is is wind and I think
Brent's already explained to you why
wind would be such an advantage to a
predator and that causes a change of
behavior and the animals that they would
hunt as well they become more nervous
they become more jumpy more alert our
app time
I put myself in the worst possible
position no okay we've got some at the
back there as well enough time for tiny
toe piece another thing animals will
often do and wind like this is they will
lie down and that just increases the
surface area that's exposed to the wind
but if you look look at that it's not
incredible the taupe is are already
growing their horns it seems like just
the other day that they were taking
their first tottering footsteps tiny and
very vulnerable looking now already how
long has that taken a month a month and
a half not even already the tiny toe
peas are growing horns here we go can
see them at the back that's phenomenal
ah Oh a wind you feel the whole car
rocking as the wind blows now in
situations like this the animals will
actually try and move to open areas this
is a perfect spot for them because the
grass is still quite short and that
means that although their sense of
hearing and their sense of smell is
compromised and compromised at least
they can see potential threats lion for
example a leopard or cheetah all of
those things they'll spot coming that's
why you'll find even in South Africa a
lot of the animals will crowd together
on an open area like quarantine
hours we try and forge our way forward
without being blown away let's go and
find out where the brand's managed to
stay in one place and is well sheltered
from the wind well we are in the exact
same place as the wind is still a
buffeting down and I'm hoping that the
voids are gonna take advantage of this
windy afternoon to try do some hunting
but at the moment oh we got a little bit
of movement a little bit of movement to
head up all the two on the right a bit
of a rollover a little bit to the right
there what are you two up to that's
that's look that's better that's better
I like that movement more and there's
possibilities possibilities although
there are still looking quite relaxed
and one must remember that sometimes
with big cats getting up is a gradual
process or sometimes the instantaneous
process never can be quite sure which
one you're going to encounter
oh look at they do they'd look seemed to
be enjoying the cool windy weather more
than we are at Lynne's wondering how
close to prey need to be for the cheetah
to get active Oh Lynn this is that is a
very good question but again it's one of
those questions where there is no finite
answer it all depends on what prey
species how hungry they are and what
size of the prey is I suppose that goes
down simple but what a species again but
all those times are different sort of
variables play a massive part in whether
the cheetah will get up and start
running if something in the right sort
of size range jogged right up to them
now there we get up very very quickly
almost instantaneously there would be up
and at it and as you can see at the
moment they're the opposite of a pen
asset and yesterday while we were
waiting for them to do something you
managed to do it a bit of birding and I
fortunately don't think that is going to
be the case today because this wind has
kept all those little grassland birds
the puppets larks wheat ears that we saw
yesterday well and truly sort of bunk it
down for the moment you never know the
wind might lay off in a little bit but I
don't think it's going to I think we
probably stuck with this wind for the
rest of the Safari and as I say it's not
a bad thing now as I said we're probably
not going to see any birds maybe Jamie
can provide some and it seems like she
already has I have actually I mean as
brain said voting is difficult in this
weather but sometimes there are other
factors that mitigate its effects and
this is a nice example of the difference
between South Africa and the Masai Mara
or at least the low felt and the low
felt you'll see waffled starlings for
the
as what do these birds are you'll see
what old starlings around the animals
but you won't often see them sitting on
the backs of the animals and just before
and while you were still with brains the
the waffle styling was sitting on the
back of the zebra and picking off ticks
and parasites so we're used to seeing
oxpeckers doing that but it's not often
that we see the wattle starlings
hitching a ride on the various animals
that in the way that we do in the Mara
of course it's very common to see birds
moving about where there are big mammals
and that's because as they move about
feeding they disturb insects that the
starlings will then run forward and grab
so what we have is the female in front
and a male at the back straw had you say
such cool-looking birds it's easy to see
where they get oh I'm sorry I think
we've actually got two males easy to see
where they get their name wattle styling
from if you have a look at the bird on
the left there you go a very very
well-developed wattle display purposes
it's much much larger in the male and in
the female which immediately tells you
what it's used for
you know we've definitely got females in
one male in terms of a reproductive
advantage display purposes look at me
I've got the biggest wattle of all so I
actually I didn't stop for the wattle
starling so that I'm glad that I did I
stopped because there's an image so
beguiling that's I just had to show it
to you of course as I say that it
decides to relieve itself but he is
there's two very beguiling little
creatures and it allows us to continue
our train of thought on the fluffy metre
the fluff ohmmeter tiny tiny little baby
zebras still a little bit unsteady on
their feet when I left this entire area
was filled with pregnant females and now
everywhere I look there's a
spindly leg baby zebra there's one off
to the right that's just about to go and
have a drink from mum pale in color when
you compare it to the adults the stripes
are sort of brownish and I think
probably falls into the same place and
the fluffa metre scale as the hyena if
not even fluffier I'm always surprised
at just how large baby zebra are even
when they're very very young and that of
course makes sense because they have to
have long legs to help to keep up with
the zebra our kisra Fox while we watch
the little baby zebra yes absolutely the
birds were using they were using the
zebra to flush out insects in the grass
something that a fork-tailed Ron go
often does back in South Africa you'll
see the drongos swooping in and out
around buffaloes and I'll take you to
see the larger flocks of wattle
starlings in a second but not yet baby
zebra are just too cute well Jake is on
the same page as I am LJ cases that they
watch baby zebra all day long they are
just so utterly adorable
there's something I don't know this I
think so innocent-looking about a baby
zebra
and if it's the eyes or the face perhaps
it's just that they have a tendency not
to be quite as angry and aggressive as
the adults generally speaking zebra are
quite short-tempered
quite angry animals at least with each
other they have very very little
patience look at its face that's too
sweet it's a nice thing about this time
of year in the Mara
there's babies everywhere and then by
the time February rolls around we've got
the wildebeest birthing season to look
forward to and while most of them have
got off back towards Tanzania the number
of them have stayed behind the Leutze
herds have stayed behind and are on the
other side of the river so we've got
baby wildebeest to look forward to as
well I was at nap time now that you've
had your lunch or afternoon tea I guess
it would be Rama do you want to know
where are all the wildebeest most of
them as I said have gone back into
Tanzania they went trotting off across
the Sand River the last final stragglers
probably about a month ago possibly even
a little bit longer so the Valda beasts
have gone but they were still around
about I think the numbers are around
between thirty and fifty thousand never
leave they remain permanently based here
so there's about three of them behind me
that I drove past unfortunately Craig
won't be able to film them it was quite
a while ago but there's about thirty or
so thousand fifteen odd thousand
wildebeest on the other side of the
river now typically the loiter herd does
its own migration back towards the
loiter hills unfortunately one of the
realities of life is such that that
migrational pattern has been changed and
has been changed by the presence of
fences
so chances are most of the loiter herd
are going to stay in that area and we'll
see them throughout the year as
apparently as B become a pretty standard
thing over the past 2 or so years sad
very very sad the fences of course was
one of the things that completely ended
the massive spring back migration that
used to happen within South Africa
larger even than the great migration
that occurs here millions of spring back
used to move across the country but with
with the increase in population with
increase in said the colonial
settlements and fences going up that
migration was completely finished it's
not something that's going to happen
here because the main route that they've
all the beasts follow to Tanzania I'm
going like that but it's actually that
way the main route that they follow will
forever remain for I hope forever
without fences so we spoke about the
waffled stylings to move on to happier
times we spoke about the wattle
starlings following the zebra and they
are but let me see if I can get us to
where they're flocking around the
buffalo because it's only one or two
stragglers that are spending time with
the zebra most of them are around this
herd of buffalo that's up ahead of us
by vice TP zebra little falls so cute
okay well I make an attempt to see where
the slock of starlings is gone let's
send you back over to Brent and here's
cats who are feeling very sleepy very
sleepy even Oh one's got its head up now
so I'm hoping there is possibly some
movement shortly the more they sort of
start rolling around and maybe even
having a little bit of a play and
grooming is is what we're looking for
means they're probably gonna start
hopefully start getting up but as as you
all know we are 100% live from the
African bush so you never know what
could happen next you can hear some we
can't even see them and I can hear some
clubbers overhead being swept away by
the wind but as if the wind wind is not
necessarily a bad thing for the cheetah
in terms of their hunting it could very
much aid them this afternoon
oh here we go here's a bit of a yawn see
those are all very good signs that
hopefully in the not too distant future
the boys are going to decide to be a
little bit more entertaining than
they've been all day
now I'm not complaining about spending a
Sunday basically emulating the cats but
on the vehicle next to them but it would
be nice after maybe probably eight hours
or so now to to get a bit of movement
now it's interesting to see which
direction they go we know where they
came from so where they're going to go
next
her David David running how often do
cheetah need to eat now again it's it's
a very dependent question depending on
what they've caught how big it is
whether they lost their carcass to
another predator so cheetah on average
use about 50% of all the kills they make
to lions or hyenas or even leopard in
some cases but if they catch a nice big
sub adult wildebeest or bigger no
probably won't have to eat for a day or
two but if they catch baby Thomson's
gazelle they're probably gonna have to
eat again today it all depends is that
rain was that just the wind it's raining
oh dear oh dear that's not good it's
still just spitting at the moment coming
from behind us and I'm not feeling it in
the car I can just hear it on the roof
but it does look like the boys are
getting ready to get up so let's just
have a quick look there we go lovely
stretch watch what they do now a little
bit of rain is also not a bad thing for
them if they are off hunting there you
go a little bit of grooming as we were
talking about all good signs that it
might be time to get up and get busy
only d'Artagnan has got his head flat to
the ground at the moment okay well we're
gonna stick with the cheetah and keep a
close eye on what the rain is doing
whether we need to deploy the tent but
while we do that it seems like Jamie has
found the Buffalo with the birds well I
guess it was rainin lattes I think that
sort of answers our question as to
what's to the south and to the east of
us so we found the birds but they're
playing hard to get
obviously the Buffalo are pretty clear
to see we've got an entire
sitting here enjoying some time resting
and ruminating in this oh there we go
Greg there they are they're in the tree
they've got back to their tree there's
this massive flock of wattled starlings
and it keeps splitting up and then
coming back together again I think most
of them stayed in that tree again quick
over to Brent
oh yeah as the cheetah got up the
gremlins attacked brains and now he's
vanished off your screens that's okay
I'm still here
and trying to find you the stock of
birds although I'm right at the point of
giving up now and moving on blind I'd
Buffalo don't be shy it's okay
rose Buffalo is blind in its left eye
probably due to some kind of traumatic
injury it's completely covered by a
cataract of course now that I'm trying
to point that out it's decided to there
we go you can see I'm almost certain
that would be complete blindness in that
eye but one eye common one-eyed common
why not animals are not that uncommon
okay
brains found signal off you go
or not hey it in theory is a lovely idea
but unfortunately in practice it seems
as though brain signals just not quite
stable enough hopefully those cheater
lead him somewhere where he can actually
show you what's happening I'm gonna move
on though I'm going to leave our our
buffalo herd we'll probably come back
here I wish I could figure out where the
ant Gamez went because if we could do
that we could determine whether or not
we should come back here towards the
evening
listen I've driven all around there and
there were no animals when I drove there
this morning which means if that if the
angles are hungry if they're not on to
kill now again I have to move up in this
direction I can see two cars up ahead of
me that haven't moved in a while that
would be pushing it for the N Garber's
it would put them right up close to the
territory of the marsh breakaway females
let's go and find out I think I'm going
to stick close to home with this weather
moving about
but windy weather it's a good hunting
times good hunting potential for those
of you that missed the sunrise Safari
speaking of hunting but saw yesterday is
sunset Safari so if you missed the
sunrise but saw the sunset I went
straight back to where the leopard had
the giraffe kill all that's left is one
slightly mangled leg in the tree the
rest of the kill he appears to have
dropped down and I think the hyenas have
dragged it away and there was no side of
him I don't think he went far but the
grass is long there there's lots of
small bushes for him to hide under and
we tried this morning but we just didn't
have any success
quick over to Brent again
standing by adisyl action
so you guys we've got we just they just
disappeared through the kiddin they've
caught a tiny baby Impala this is not
for sensitive viewers we couldn't get to
the hand we were actually came through
the thickets they're ramming into the
thickets when they saw this tiny baby
and pilot so fortunately with so many of
them it's going to be gone very quickly
and I'm not gonna suffer at all I mean
you can see it's so small that you can't
even see the Impala
d'Artagnan 'he's late to the feast
as I said there's this windy weather
will often benefit them is that I don't
think the Impala all the other animals
heard them as they started charging
through the bush
we can yeah them fighting
so you can actually hear some of those
strange noises Cheeta make and sad that
this is not gonna last very long it's
gonna be gone in two seconds if it's not
almost already all gone
I'd say it's a couple of days old so a
lot of the bones will be all of the
bones will be very very soft so they're
gonna be able to chew through most of
them you can every now and then you'll
just catch a glimpse you can see how
small the little ribs are and that tells
you how young the Impala was and you can
see how even cheetah with their non
powerful jaws on working through the rib
bones very easy it might be one or two
bigger vertebrae they might struggle
with but I think probably not on an
Impala that size
you can see one always pops at a nap
making sure that there's no potential
threats close by because even with this
wind
hyenas sense of hearing was so good and
that baby Impala did bleat a little bit
if there was a hyena close very close to
here then it definitely would have
reacted and I'm keeping a close look at
but even if the hyenas did arrive now I
don't think there'd be much for them
Khan lapwings have arrived we had them
alarm calling at the cheetah
James Richard says once these boys get
moving they sure get things done quickly
isn't that the truth
that was a split second from when they
were sort of lying about bit of grooming
and all of a sudden one just took off
through the Croton thickets they say it
should be quick sticks to finish this
probably just a little bit of skin left
now
I still keeping a lookout
George is saying surprise they're not
fighting more over such a small meal
well at the moment there we go as much
as soon as it gets less then there will
be a little bit more fighting so the
d'Artagnan 'he's got off with the
biggest piece even though he was the
last to arrive and didn't actually make
a kill at all and as i say that an
impala of that size is not going to
provide very much food at all for these
five boys
I'm just gonna move back a little bit so
he can see oh and it's a see if I make
an attempt to take the kill back thought
about it so make sure there's no cars
behind this yeah we never know here we
go how's that future so there's a little
bit of a battle going on over the pelvis
by the looks of things and with other
two there one's got its grips on it now
that might be their only burn the top
pelvis and the thighs it might be a bit
too big so since some of the vertebra
might be too big for them to crunch up
it's incredible how fast and if wind you
can see it playing and if the flowers
around the flame Nica flowers
they were like lightning
Adrian's wondering are they not afraid
of being attacked by bigger predators
very Adrienne well here we go are we
gonna get a little bit of a playful from
d'Artagnan maybe not so yes there are
very much so
Adrienne that's why there aren't quite
quite alert on a small carcass like this
they'll try to eat as much as possible
as quickly as possible why she on all
carcasses is what she to do in case a
larger predator makes an appearance and
can disappear with it so on average as I
say they lose about 50% of all their
kills to larger predators
that's wind definitely worked in their
favor this afternoon
making short work in UNC finishing off
so they've managed to match him Munsch
up a lot of the pelvis they're now down
onto the little legs
Andrea's commenting on that wind it is
it is it is particular strong is
actually probably dropped off a little
bit in the last half an hour compared to
what it was I said during the middle of
the day was when it was at its worst it
was really really strong and the boys
were just hunkered down in the thickets
here yep I'll clean you if you clean me
the buns in coalition's where there be
cheetah or lion are always very
important so even though they were
scrapping over the scraps of the meal a
little bit of a lower grooming and
cleaning each other is very important
especially after those little scraps to
reaffirm the bonds between the coalition
members you gotta fight from a tail
oh here we go speaking in
Johnathan's wondering what determines
when or how what who the cause of the
Musketeers to possibly split up it'll be
a dominance play between between the
different cheater so they're still quite
young and when they start breeding
that's what that'll be whether they're
going to stick together or not whether
one or two or maybe even three of them
are happy with her vis the dominating
and do the pradhan most of the breeding
or is not happy with that situation and
there might split up then of course the
more common reason for cheated
coalition's to become fewer in number is
lions
lions are the greatest threat to cheetah
out here on a day-to-day basis
here we go here's the fighting custody
is wondering is one of the cheetah
wearing a collar yes it is that is
d'Artagnan and he's been collared by the
Mara cheetah project and he's part of an
ongoing research program on a dispersal
male cheetah hey boys well done
that didn't last long China say I'm
pretty sure they're gonna hunt again
once they've finished off the last of
this baby Impala probably hoped for
something a bit bigger you can see how
quickly it's taken them to almost
completely eat every single scrap
disturb bit of skin left
whoa when nearly blew my hat off
until ago you can see not much left at
all
getting it mouth full of fur there as I
was talking about the bonds between
coalition's are very important and the
affection you see between the different
individuals is very important in the
maintaining of a strong coalition as
soon as there's less affection it'll
probably mean that the coalition is
likely to split and they say it's going
to be very difficult to see until they
start competing from mating rights
whether they will stay together or
whether they will split as it didn't
take them long to scoff that ad wall
still no sign of hyenas or vultures
especially with this wind I think
everyone's going to struggle a little
bit - yeah even the vultures might
struggle to fly they might get above it
there so there we go you can see that
very important ritual cleaning it's
cleaning the blood off each other but
it's also reaffirming those bonds
because they might have given each other
a smack while feeding or a smell or a
bite so it's very important for that
that the chetan are to reestablish will
reaffirm those coalition bonds
go bears rendering other coalition boys
bigger in size than a single male
cheater in this era I would not say so
at all today they're pretty good size
actually some of them are quite small
compared to some of the male cheetahs
I've seen in the Mario but there are so
young and they're still filling out but
I wouldn't say they're any bigger than a
cheetah that was by itself or a
coalition of two male cheetahs
now brent is wondering what is a king
cheetah and a king cheetah is color
morphing into a genetic mutation in
terms of where the spots fusing become
stripes and it is only in southern
Africa Botswana Zimbabwe and South
Africa the only place King cheetah have
ever been rewarded and the last one in
the wild was in the 70s so a long time
ago so it's like leucism leucism which
is a lack of pigment it's a it's
actually a stimulation of mineral ISM
but not full minute ism which would make
a black cheetah it's just a produced
amendment and the spots are fused into
stripes
this wind is horrible but good if you're
a hunting cheater Matt's wondering will
the Cheetah Hunt again right away or
will there wait a while and they'll do a
bit of grooming but I think they will
get up and move
not necessarily tant but they're on the
move so it is possible and they'll hunt
again almost immediately or they could
wait a while and I've seen them do both
so it all just depends
Shelly says their head their food so
fast is that going to make them sleepy
well they've got very high metabolisms
and that wasn't a lot of food and they
can eat a lot more than that very
quickly so they might have a little rest
but I still think they will be moving on
in not too long
now ah there you go
d'Artagnan still got a few little
snippets but other than that it's all
done
pod cat mama would like to know is there
an average amount the cheetah will hunt
per day no it is again one of those
questions that is completely dependent
on the circumstance so there is no
average there catch a big valle de beast
there won't hunt for two days and but if
they catch a baby Impala like this they
might hunt for five baby impala baby
Thomson's gazelle in a day so there's no
seat an average amok the cheetah will
hunt in a day
yeah well we're gonna stick with them
see if they do get on the move and on
the hunt again while we do that Jamie's
still searching for big cats of home
well I haven't found a big cat but from
one endangered species to another most
definitely not a big cats but quite a
big there we go what a lovely surprise I
saw some vehicles earlier on looking all
gathered together in this particular
spot and I was wondering if maybe they'd
found the line but this is this is just
as good a pair of black rhino one of
whom is enjoying a Sunday afternoon
snooze and it looks as though the two of
them have spent the day at the spa in
fact that one has got mud almost over
its entire body you missed a spot
my friend just right at the top so
you'll never see a rhino rolling right
over onto its back hence why the top of
the shoulders doesn't have any mud on it
but the rest of it does rhinos love a
mud wallow and it has been hot today
even though it is windy so a really good
opportunity for us to have a look at
well a couple of different features of
the black rhinoceros and what makes it
different from the white rhinoceros
first of all the shape of the head the
way that the head is held because we
call in black rhinoceros technically
they hook clipped rhinoceros and you can
see why with that hook lips rather than
the wide lip of the white rhinoceros and
they use that to break off branches it's
quite a prehensile lip branches leaves
anything like that will form part of its
diet as opposed to the grass of the
other species now I was a bit worried
when I first drove up because often wind
can in particular with Rhino make them
rather unsettled makes total sense as to
why they're very very short-sighted
their eyesight is it's terrible to say
the least they pick up on movement but
only at around about
50 yard yards and usually their
responses to try and investigate it and
to try and smell it rather than to
actually try and see because they just
can't the carbs eyesight is a bit better
than the adults but the adults have a
very keen sense of smell and a very keen
sense of hearing now at the moment our
smells been blown away from them so they
know that something's here and the one
on the left is particularly alert they
know that something's here and they've
probably aware that it's vehicles
because they can probably hear the sound
of the engines and people talking but it
does the wind has made their lives more
difficult I love the fact that we can
share Rhino with you electric floss did
I hear that ROG electric floss electric
floss Arana will typically in the wild
hi how are you good thanks it has been a
long time yes sorry about this sloth
electric floss sorry where the lines I
don't know you tell me no I mean either
okay cheese man it's good to see you
again
hi guys apologies electric floss
electric sloth is that it is it electric
sloth right I'm sorry it's terrible just
see one of the other guides that I've
got to know recently over the past few
weeks and I haven't seen him in a while
because I've been uneven he's obviously
been on leave right electric sloth got
it finally apologized and Arana will
typically live between 30 and 40 years
up to 40 years in the wild so their long
lived animals and that applies to to
male and female as well 30 to 40 odd
years it's a long time and how long they
should live at any rate another thing
about a black rhino just while it turns
its head and I'm not sure whether we've
got a male or a female here I'm inclined
to say it's a female but it's difficult
to judge with size because of course a
female can live for 40 years I have seen
female Rhino that are just as large as
their male counterparts it's more tricky
but as she presents what it presents its
profile it's another thing about black
rhino you'll find particularly in older
animals is that the secondary horn so
the one that is behind the shorter one
that will often grow almost as long as
the front horn at times they even look
as though they're going to touch as they
grow now for new viewers this is a very
important fact to talk about a rhino
horn is made of keratin it is the same
substance essentially obviously
different different way that it's
structured and laid out but essentially
it is the same substance as your hair
and as your fingernails which is what
makes it so tragic that it's used
medicinally because there is absolutely
zero medicinal value in a rhino horn you
might as well go and eat a bowl full of
your own hair
perhaps clipping from clippings from a
beard or chew your own fingernails
doesn't sound very appetizing does it
but the sad reality is that there is a
belief
that it helps with all sorts of things
from hangovers to colds to cancer to
other human conditions prodcut mama only
in the beginning so proud cat mom is
wondering I promised you I'd find a
picture of the the Rhino growth and I
completely forgot I've got it somewhere
the horn can only be used in determining
age when the Rhino is still young and
it's used in combination with the size
of the Rhino next to its mother and once
they reach around about the age of let's
say hmm 8 or 9 even up to 10 after that
it becomes more tricky to tell whether
or not or to gauge the Rhinos age the
best way to do it of course is the is
the condition of their teeth but again
as I always say when I talk about that
you have to get a rhino to open wide and
they generally don't do that so once
they've reached that age the horn grows
continuously that's one of the reasons
that's put forward in terms of dehorning
rider and why they have to if you do D
horn them you have to deal on them every
five or so years but they rub their
horns down at the horn continues to grow
so you can't really utilize it but I
mentioned that the secondary horn often
in older individuals grows up to the
size of the first that will give you a
little bit of an idea but it's not
accurate and just like human beings you
know how some people's hair grows very
very quickly some people's fingernails
grow quickly some people's fingernails
grow slowly it'll be the same with rhino
and that horn used for defense and for
males used for backing off other males I
think this is a female and a calf that
one and the one that's lying down to me
looks quite small probably around the
region of three years old if she hasn't
had another baby by now then that would
be the right age
she's got an ox picker friend oh no she
doesn't anymore she had an ox picker
my worlds your music none which is very
sad so why will your music is wondering
about white rhino and if there are any
left there are none in the Mara which is
a pity and the reason it's such a pity
is because this is such a perfect
habitat for them so black rhino tend to
favor quite closed habitats they will
come out into the open like this but
really they like to be in dense
vegetation where is a white rhino loves
a Sumida field in other words they love
red grass and there's plenty of that to
go around and this probably would have
an enormous carrying capacity when it
comes to white rhino but unfortunately
there aren't any there's probably
somewhere in the region the numbers we
have to get we'll have to get an
accurate count but there's in the region
of around about 50 odd black rhino in
the Mara
so this massive massive area we're so
lucky to see them as often as we do
hopefully no not hopefully definitely
that numbers growing so that number
grows all the time there are protected
here and there's always a ranger around
these sightings making sure that these
Rhino are safe and in fact she's in the
best possible place where she is
hey girl I think it's a girl another
thing to look at of course is speaking
of them being monitored and looked after
see those cuts and Nick's on her ears
those are artificial so she would have
been darted and those would have been
cut into her ears by a vet the reason
being it's the quickest and easiest way
of identifying individuals and when
you've got a population as small as this
it's important to be able to monitor
each and every single individual it's
important to be able to recognize them
so what you'll find is that they'll have
identity kits where the it's basically a
drawing of a Rhinos face and each one
has got different notches in their ears
which then helps to determine exactly
which individual it was my favorite
Rhino in the whole wide world
whereas a female called notches and the
reason she was called notches was she
had three right next to each other who
in fact her whole year the whole side of
her ear was completely notched by the
people who had notched her when she was
a calf
she'll said a split horn so she had
almost looked like she had three horns
Knox Beck is coming back so while our
affectionate female Rhino stands guard
over a calf which I'm almost a hundred
percent certain is the Senora that we
have here let's go across to a bonding
session between the Musketeers there we
go you can see lots of bonding going on
and a tiny little patch of skin on the
ground is all that's left
and obviously I'm sure you can hear the
gale force wind that is really it seems
to have got stronger again the boys
don't seem to mind there remember this
is a hundred percent live coming to you
from the Maasai Mara in Kenya and we're
with the largest known coalition of male
cheetah five boys together and they
recently if you just joined us killed a
young Impala but that's not going to
suffice for these boys The Hunger is
there they're concave bellies they're
gonna be up and on the move again
looking for some more potential prey but
first it's time to just lie on a termite
mound because that's what you do when
you're a cheater
as I said I don't think it'll be too
long before they're up and on the move
again they've got incredibly fast
metabolisms so they digest whatever they
kill very very quickly and something
like that's more that's more shared
between four of them is not even going
to touch sides
one of them's sporting a little bit of a
limp Virginia likes so much one of the
boys is the oldest I'm not sure it's
almost impossible to tell at this age
sorry the wind is about to take me away
it's impossible decide and if you can
hear me over there
then I'm gonna dry up on my head down so
you can hear me over this wind it's
impossible to tell which which which of
the boys is the oldest and they're all
roughly around the same age just about
two also two two and a half I'd guess I
might be wrong if I remember correctly
that's how all their here's the one
who's got a little bit of a limp nothing
serious
and as I said I think there will be on
the movie in shortly but I think they
might have a little snooze beforehand
all coming to join now all five will be
on the same termite mound shortly
and see some Valda beasts in the
distance but I'm not sure they're gonna
head that direction right on the
opposite value there
so lady lair would like to know when is
the cheetah mating season well like all
big cats and domestic cats and dogs
there is no set of mating season and
they're made throughout the year and
only at when the female comes into East
hrus and that is when they will mate oh
wind go away I can't even think with
this wind pounding through yet
so it is you see how they're cleaning
their feet now um and they will do a bit
of grooming while they get rid of the
blood that's left over from that baby
Impala probably because it tastes quite
nice as well now very very cleanly cats
well not really you know quite smelly
and they'll be full of parasites and
fleas and ticks but as wild animals go
they do tend to like to keep themselves
quite neat and tidy
Oh windy windy windy still wonder if
they're gonna headed in the same
direction they were heading when they
started moving or are they gonna change
their direction completely and head
towards those for the beasts in the
distance mm I don't know I think they're
probably gonna head further to the west
again now how do you would like to know
how large is this um cheetahs these
cheetahs home range well they have a
they actually have a territory being
males and their territory will have a
core area and a less cool area the male
cheetah can have a territory of up to 30
plus thousand Hector's over 60,000 acres
but their core range within that will
probably be about half now it also all
depends on whereabouts in Africa you are
so for example these cheetah have a much
smaller territory than a cheetah that
lives in the desert in Namibia would
have because of prey abandon see so
because there's a lot of prey they don't
need a lot of territory now female
cheetah have home ranges that overlap
with other female cheetah and they can
be much bigger than the males
and so what males try to do is form the
core part of their territory around an
area where multiple female home ranges
overlap because otherwise they would
never ever find a girlfriend
heads are still all up nearly all clean
not quite but nearly now even with this
howling gale
the vultures managed to spot the
teachers I'm not sure from where but
they're there waiting quite patient be
on the other side while the boys are
napping the vultures are waiting for
them to move away from the remnants of
that carcass as one two three four five
six seven eight I don't think there's
enough food left for eight vultures but
they will they will try yeah I'm gonna
try reposition a little bit so this wind
isn't
blowing me away but while we do that
let's go across to Jamie and Jafar ooh
there we go our little one is up and
following along them behind mum
so we well I was correct it was a female
and a car that looked like it was a
little one at the back so two and a half
fish maybe yeah
two and a half fish little spray of
urine there I think it might be a boy
it's hard to tell because of course they
don't spray their urine property until
they reach sexual maturity in which case
their urine sprays backwards might also
just to be in the wind so there goes mom
in hello we're talking about rhino and
white rhino in the Mara remember that it
would have been a different subspecies
as well that would have been found in
this area the northern white rhino and
of course unfortunately although not
extinct yet the northern white rhino has
reached the point of extinction the last
remaining wild male white rhino his name
is Sudan and he lives he lives in Kenya
not in the Mara though so unfortunately
if white right are reintroduced back
into this area it will have to be
southern white rhino
because Sudan has reached the point
where he's essentially passed breeding
age and finding him a female even from a
zoo while it has been done has not
proved to be successful in the birth of
a northern white rhino calf
Hey look at the typical head-up approach
I'm gonna do a quick I'm just gonna wait
for this vehicle to come past me and
then I'll turn around Laura wouldn't it
be easier to tattoo the Rhinos ears
instead of cutting them no I'll give you
I'll give you one very very clear reason
why that would not be a better idea
first of all this - there's two reasons
first of all tattooing could could
actually take a fair amount of time
which the longer and a Rhino is under
anesthetic the more dangerous it becomes
Rhino do die a lot of animals there's
always a potential risk just like with
human beings of general anaesthetic so
that's one of the problems this second
problem is the big one remember we said
this rhinos covered in mud now if it's
were to have a good spa day that spa day
would reach it all the way it would be
covered in mud from the tips of its toes
to the tips of its ears and the tattoo
would be covered up completely and that
of course would make things very
difficult whereas notches stand out very
clearly so it's done quickly they're
immediately given antibiotics as soon as
that's been done a long-acting
antibiotic Jambo long-acting antibiotic
as well as some antibiotic spray and
they go on their way probably yes with a
slightly sore ear but it heals quickly
and they often do it to themselves and
then you have to add it to their
identity kit they often repose in their
ears to retreating bottoms
what a lovely citing they've given us
mum and little one it's see if I can see
what little one is Oh
Stark I think it's a boy think it's a
male yep it's a male the young male
cough
so tricky to tell like with elephants
the testicles of the Rhino the male
Rhino obviously are internal so it's not
always obvious so easy not they're
spectacular
the whole cars rocking as the wind blows
I've got my head ducked down in the
almost in the footwell so that you can
hear me over the wind okay as we say
goodbye to our Rhino and I'd duck below
and shelter I think that Brent is
experiencing something very similar on
the other side of the river well we're
trying to keep ourselves out of the wind
and still keep a close eye on the
Musketeers but they're still on top of
that termite mound heads are still up
there which is always a good thing
after a little afternoon tea snack
they're having a little rest before
their head off on the move again I'm
pretty sure they're gonna move oh there
we go
come on that's it are you gonna get
everyone going oh no we're just going
I'm just going to do some kisses so some
more grooming between the different
individuals
isn't that gorgeous
there's a little bit of rain about often
all the winds decided to creep back in
again I thought we had managed to
position our backside towards the
majority of the wind but it keeps
swirling yeah we've been lucky enough to
spend the whole day with these these
boys even with with this incredible
howling gale it has been quite a
pleasant day
and you can see a big cold front is
being blown in by the scale I had a look
um at a nap earlier that shows you the
wind and whatnot and you could just see
this these green streaks of wind
throughout the whole of the East Africa
today of all the majority of East Africa
is experiencing these in this incredible
wind
so really wondering which way they're
gonna go
there's some big congregations of
wildebeest to the south and to the
little the east of us and don't know
what's over the next little rise but
they could quite easily be stuff that's
moved in there during the day that
wasn't there earlier today there general
roots at the moment there have been sort
of very much staying in this area I
think there might head a little bit
further down to the west back down
towards the wrong guy Valley and never
had some very successful hunting in that
area there's still quite a bit of the
still quite a few of all the beasts
around now of course these Valda bees
that are not part of the main migration
that moves between the Serengeti and the
Maasai Mara they are from the loiter
herd the loiter herd remains resident in
Kenya throughout the year they don't
always stay in the Mara itself they do
move out of the Mara towards the loiter
Hills and that's where they get their
name that's their traditional birthing
ground but last year they didn't seem to
go all the way to loiter and they stayed
in the Mara well some of them stayed in
the Mara and it's gonna be very
interesting to see what they do this
year coming
oh he's to having very affectionate
maybe one smacked the other one a little
bit hard while they were eating on that
Impala Denise is wondering do the
Cheetahs ever come after our tracks
no they've got no reason to we're not
food we don't smell like food we smell
like petrol or diesel and oil what is
that cheetah spotted nothing just
sitting up and so no there and also
cheetah will try avoid conflict with
anything too big even even a large zebra
male would be a bit too much even for
five boys like this so no there they do
not come after our tracks neither do the
lines no they don't
as long as you drive carefully in
respectfully and you don't irritate the
animals and push them into corners and
they should never ever come after us in
the vehicles and the vehicles only been
around for about just over a hundred
years so the animals have have no real
understanding of it they do not have a
instinctive response and they haven't
evolved around vehicles so for example
if you stood up on the bonnet where a
cheetah or lion or a leopard could see
the bipedal figure of man and they've
all been competing with hominins whether
it be us or our ape-like ancestors for
many many moons that will cause them to
react differently however in the vehicle
they don't see that bipedal figure that
don't have an instinctive response to
that so they're completely ignore us
while we're in the vehicle now you do
get animals that can be a bit skittish
around vehicles and that's but genuine
they haven't seen them at all and that's
when you've got to really gradually I
climatized them to the vehicle habituate
them to the vehicle but know that most
almost all animals or I want to have
very little to do with our vehicles
where to next fellas
what adventure are you going to take us
on next mister Musketeers well we're
gonna stay here trying to hunker down
from the howling gale while we do that
let's go see what Jamie's up to on the
other side of the Mara I'm looking for a
place to hunker down from the gale but I
can't hunker down from the gale without
an animal next to me so where have all
the Lions gone this place is full of
lions why can I not find one or a
leopard or cheetah I'm not fussy morano
have gone so I can't hunt calder uncle
cool hunker down next to them so we just
have to brave the climatic conditions
until we find ourselves a cat or an
elephant or something look there we go
oh these roads are the ones the worst
hit when it rains
unfortunately they're dry at the moment
but it does make for a rather bumpy
passage craig is that a lion or a log
it's a log log a lot of line logs today
sign log just cheated termite mounds
leopard bushes I'm really good at it
even the black belly busted is miserable
Nani we're gonna do is call cuz what's
the point
the voice will just get blown away or
not I don't I don't know that you're
going to be able to hear that call it is
one of the best bird calls I think in
the world but with this wind howling the
way it is I don't think you'll hear
anything unfortunately well you we will
hear something and that's just wind on
microphone noise well at least he's sort
of semi enthusiastic he just seems to
tuck his head in as soon as he possibly
can one will go for us because the
motion is entertaining I'll try and do
the call I'll try and time it with his
call
no nice shy he doesn't want a voice-over
artist that's fair I don't do a very
good impression anyway no that didn't
work right well it's blowing a gale out
here in the Maasai Mara I'm not sure
what the conditions are on Juma this
afternoon but let's send you all the way
across to South Africa where Noel has
found something next to the water
Thank You Jamie we do have something
interesting next to the water it is a
foam nest frogs nest it's the first one
I've seen here in Juma for the season so
the foam nest frogs the mound the female
get up on there and he does something
called
em plexus he sits on top and she rubs
her legs and they deposits this nest
with their goodies inside and then the
little babies when they hatch they eat
through and then drop into the water and
then carry on their lifecycle from there
again good afternoon I am Noel and on
camera we have the French Connection
Sebastian hello it is humid very very
very warm this afternoon don't forget we
are interactive we are live you can
follow us hash tag as Safari live on the
Twitter or on YouTube chat and we love
your questions to send them through send
them through all right back to frog
mating and there's a beautiful little
friction that's coming up over that bit
of foam this frog nests there so it's
very obvious they're very very white and
they'll do it over these little seasonal
pans to catch whatever rainwater has
been deposited in these pans and then
for the rest of the season you'll see
them they're very interesting I find
them in my house often they change their
color from a sort of gray color to a
white color depending on the heat and
and and whether they're in the Sun or
not to help protect themselves and when
when they're not meeting like this they
are hibernating to to a point but they
just find a nice of a moist area where
they where they can reside but for now
it is definitely a frog that we will
hear when it gets a little bit cooler
and I'm hoping we can manage that later
this afternoon
all right plans Sebastian and I are
sweating quite heavily so we run short
of plans concrete plans at the moment
I've been hearing more about these
cheetah that have come through from the
money let's see they're still just
tracking as far as I know there hasn't
been any sign of them but they were
heading east and south which means
hopefully hopefully they'll pop up in
our general area
um Tommy went back to her den site this
morning we have no visual on her husana
last I heard last night was that little
gallery so we'll try for him and then I
think maybe we'll head over to chitwa
chitwa Dam but while we're busy heading
over to the dam hoping for some
elephants let's head over to Tristan who
would love to say hello I would love to
say hello a few drives off so it's
always nice to be back out in the bush
and being out in the wonderful sunshine
as no I'll mentioned my name is Tristan
on camera today I've got a VM the Volvo
beast and as you saw we were gazing upon
a beautiful torch with its providing
some shade for us now we are coming to
you live and interactive from the sabi
sands so that means hashtags for I live
on Twitter or YouTube chat if you would
like to get hold of us now the plan for
the afternoon is I'm not quite sure I've
just come along mulches Nest and just
driving around this area to see maybe we
get lucky with some sign of tündi at the
end of the days I'm sure if she still
got the den and she's still at that
particular area she's quite to go for
what at some point and so I'm hoping to
try and find tracks I know that's
apparently build VM said to me that
James had tracks for her this morning on
walk in this particular area so we're
just having a little look around see if
she's maybe not at one of these water
halls and then from there we're gonna
hit towards cheetah Kaplan and just
check around checkout line and see maybe
just maybe ting gone across tin from
torture but I believe it was in torture
this morning so that's the kind of plan
for this afternoon but we'll take
whatever it comes it's like I say really
nice to be out soft a bit of so cold
where that rain I haven't spent too much
time art and it's nice to see how green
it's become and I'm sure there's lots of
interesting things to look at so it
should be a wonderful afternoon just to
check on those little mud wallows and
have a little look then then maybe
you'll do up towards central and then
along from there towards cheetah Cap'n I
can't really go up towards Purple's a
dam with Gauri or pizza down at the
moment it's probably not going to be the
best idea tea after that we are pretty
sure we won't have too much in the way
of signals so we'll try and stick to the
central parts of Jummah we'll hang
around the model
a little bit and hopefully we'll get
lucky with one of our spotted cats if
not it doesn't really matter there's
lots of other things out and about them
the woodlands kingfishers are going
absolutely crazy today
they've been non-stop as they are
probably for the rest of the matter of
this summer so we're gonna hear lots of
them and I'm sure there'll be lots of
interesting birds out there should be a
few butterflies after a bit of rain and
having some sunshine like this so the
milliwatts II will be a wonderful place
to check for butterflies and well
anything else that we can get along the
way will be wonderful as well now while
I'm driving down Bulger's nest at the
moment it's quite a difficult road now
because of the amount of rain that's
falling it's it's kind of washed the
road Keenan's become very hard and so
I'm trying to just check on all the
sandy areas for any signs of footprints
of one of our cats because ultimately if
tündi did cross anywhere here I doubt
she's gonna walk on the road too much
it's it's a typical thing of cats that
are that have Cubs and are busy Denning
is that they don't actually walk on
roads in a sort of linear pattern what
they do is they generally just cross
over and the reason why they do that is
because it makes it much harder for
things like hyenas to actually follow
them because they sink gets lost in the
grasses as a person just walking along
the road hyenas can pick them up quite
easily now somebody who has not battled
to find a spot sad cat this afternoon is
my friend but Rensselaer Smith all the
way in the Maasai Mara and I'm sure he's
having a wonderful time as he follows
their sleek slender spotted beauties
around for the afternoon
well they haven't moved at all and still
on top of their termite mound and
perusing and the surrounds and there's
not much else about I'm close by to them
at the moment but as we know that can
change in a split second as it did a
little bit earlier this evening when
they jetted off after that baby Impala
you can see some imposing clouds making
their way in being pushed in by this
Gale forced wind we're experiencing
today now remember this is a live
African safari and you are able than to
ask us questions by using the hashtag
Safari live on whatever platform you
might be watching on
sigh birds would like to know what bird
is faster than the cheetah besides a
peregrine falcon well the answer to that
is many lots plenty a huge amount lots
and lots of birds any of your small
little Raptors your gas Hawks your
acceptors will all be able to to
probably get faster than that
I'm sure turns swallows what am I
thinking I'm definitely missing some
seabirds that I can probably go quite a
bit faster I mean give you give you an
example a black-bellied busted which is
which is not a very streamline or agile
looking bird is capable of flying at 65
70 kilometres an hour so if they can do
that speed I'm pretty sure there's lots
of other birds that are going to be able
to absolutely wipe the cheetah if they
were on a flat line race and of course
birds don't have to touch the ground so
less friction and so there's quite a
numerous bird species that are actually
faster than a cheetah
Sushil is wondering are cheaters able to
eat much faster than the other big cats
probably not they just need to eat a lot
faster than the other big cats so
they're they need to because they are
the chance of them losing their kill to
the other big cats or hyenas is very
very very high a 50% chance that they're
gonna lose their kill so I'd say all the
big cats can gulp it down and I've seen
lion and leopard do it when they're
about to lose their meal to another lion
or a leopard but it is not something
they have to do as often as cheetah do
and on bigger parade she told mommy
start at the rump most meat no bones and
it enables them to get as much down as
possible before their kill is stolen in
certain in certain cases a alone cheetah
will even relinquish its kill to a big
enough group of vultures I've seen 60
vultures take chase a cheetah or fur
kill and a bite from a vultures beak
might do some damage to the cheetah that
will cause it not to be able to run or
hunt obviously when you're in a
coalition it's a little bit easier
you've got some backup and you don't
have to do all the killing yourself so
when you're a single animal it is a
little bit you ought to be a lot more
careful and you take a lot less chances
now there's another animal that's not
going to do too much moving during the
daytime hours it likes to wallow about
it'll be a little bit lazy but it does
it in the water let's see what Noel has
found it reminds me
all right everyone sorry my connection
has come off
excuse me about that hippos yeah it
which it with them in front of chitwa
chitwa lodge alright so this morning I
had an extremely interesting question
about do hippos get leeches on them and
it's not something that I had ever one
thought of or two ever heard of and so I
did a little bit of research this
afternoon
regarding that and I asked a few of my
guiding friends that have been in the
industry for quite a long time they also
have never heard of hippos having
leeches something that's interested
without being able to show you a leech I
think let's look at the hippo without
having a leech in front of us and
without being able to show the sort of
body structure and things to you I just
want to talk a little bit about them
leeches are not wholly parasitic they're
not a parasite or sanguinis all the time
it's not that they need the blood all
the time very similar to an ox pecker
what they mainly feed on as adults would
be dead snails dead freshwater snails
and when the little ones are little they
feed on live smaller snails just as a
thought so
they're more opportunistic when it comes
to their their need for blood and it's
not something that they need all the
time the hippos are agreeing with me
and never tire of that sound so as we
came up there he can teach it which it
was lodged in the background as we came
up sub and I were very envious of these
hippos moving about in the water as it
is so hot and humid at the moment it
looks like we might get rain a little
bit later in the afternoon if not us
possibly someone near as I could think
you guys can see that sort of cloudy
cloudy build up in that sky there and
hopefully it won't be too thick
hopefully we'll still get a very nice
sunset this afternoon now sadly there
are no elephants swimming or bathing in
the dam as we had hoped
just our chiki chiki chiki hippos and
I'm actually on the lookout for our tiny
little hippo that was born a couple last
week let's say eight days ago I feel
like the other two have grown immensely
in size I know there was one born sort
of towards the end of October and he's
probably doubled in size since then but
you'll notice with a lot of aquatic
mammals hippo whales things like that is
that the the milk is super super rich
from the mums and so their growth rate
is quite large especially when it comes
to to Wales for hippos it's not as quick
but it is essential because the
Predators that would things like
crocodile but then also with movements
in their in their habitat now we're
focusing in on the youngsters for you
here sort of playing with the moment
every time we do this the ones off
camera keep yawning and I swear I swear
they're doing this on purpose so we're
gonna go back to these to keep
displaying so that yawn is called a gape
ya see now they want to hide their very
camera shy I'm so sorry everyone that
yawn is called a gape and some of it is
stretching just to get everything moving
as it cools down before it goes dark and
then they come out of the water but it's
also a bit of a display basically look
how large my touch are look at the size
of my mouth
and and specifically for large males
it's a show of dominance and then for
younger males it's a play on that or
when they get a little bit older
can we hear all the birdshot are in the
background
proud cat mama you're asking how you
tell the age of a hippo so proud mama
for me when they're younger it's a lot
easier especially with the size of their
head in relation to Mom's head but then
sort of after about a year too
they're pretty much fully grown year to
three years so they're just that's that
age I couldn't tell you with an adult
hippo unless it was very very old to be
able to say it's very very old this is a
thigh I'm glad you guys can hear all
that bird chatter in the background we
have a huge amount of weavers both
red-billed Buffalo Weaver's village
weavers and I think it's the southern
mass weavers that I'm seeing now busy
building nests we've got lots of Buffalo
red the Buffalo Weaver's inside this
dead tree here and then over towards our
10:00 o'clock there's a stamp at our
10:00 o'clock there's a Kingfisher that
just landed to display near these
weavers sorry guys we all love a
woodland Kingfisher there we go just
flew up and had its wings out was
displaying and there's a second one
flying in just below beautiful there we
go yeah
basically showing off for each other
look at me look at me how pretty I am
mate with me
there's the water thick knee or dick
oppa's it used to be called calling in
the background there and then they're
off oh he splashed down he's back had a
little drink there we were chatting
yesterday when we saw the woodland about
the bean insectivorous and I forgot to
mention that I've also seen them
catching small lizards and eating them I
was sitting at dinner one night many
years ago with guests and we had a small
little watering hole and one dug down
just to the edge and picked up what
looked like a skink or gecko rather the
gecko and came up and ate it
we're trying to see if they'll display
again for us so you can see that flash
of blue and then you'll notice they'll
turn as well so they'll open their wings
they flash them then they turn so you
can see that bright bright white it
would be similar to us as humans sort of
putting on full makeup and having a nice
outfit and and and and showing showing
off and yes guys you are correct it is a
beautiful beautiful beautiful bird now
with the weavers just getting my
binoculars out
you can see josub you're reading my mind
today these ones are not in full
breeding colors and I actually feel like
I just got a view of what could be a
sociable Weaver
on the side they're blown off and then
there's some females mixed in there as
well very sort of drab looking I want
the Sun to come out from behind the
cloud so we can see that little pop of
yellow but it's unfortunately not doing
hahaha there we go there you can start
to see that pop of yellow a little bit
more now with the woodland Kingfisher
both the male and female are those
beautiful bright bright colors but with
these weavers that we're looking at the
males will go into a very bright
breeding color scenario very very very
yellow and then depending on the species
sometimes they get a little bit of
orange or rust on the side and then the
females are sort of drab like this it's
more the males that need to display
their skills building the nest and the
color as well as opposed to the females
they're gonna choose off of their
that one on the top left is having
difficulty with that barrage sorry men
choose another one yeah
Kathy you're wondering if they ever
impale themselves on the thorns Kathy I
have very rarely seen birds and pail
themselves on thorns so these little
bits that are sticking out here are
what's known as a spine so it's a
modified branch so it so it is pointy at
the end but they can also grab on to it
quite nicely with their with their feet
they've got passerine feet so three toes
forward one toe back that allows them to
grip quite nicely I have seen juveniles
of some larger birds sort of trying to
navigate within a spiny or a thorny bush
and having some difficulty but I haven't
seen too much problems with with them
and paling themselves I came here are
Deirdre CooCoo in the background can we
hear it
I think the weavers are too loud that
deer deer deer do drugs we're still on
the hunt for the Colossus cuckoo I heard
one this afternoon
[Music]
wonderful sound I heard when the south
afternoon and James Richardson I thought
of you I am determined between my
self-interest and this will definitely
happen we're gonna get you across as
cuckoo on camera I refuse to let this
season go by and have it not happen your
phantom bird but we all have a bird like
that we all have a bird that sort of
gets away from us there we can see one
of the youngsters from the hippos
resting on the mum who said there's a
really beautiful view just in front of
us at about half 12 of that three-banded
clever in this little perfect if the
sun's just peeking through that's really
gorgeous picking up insects on the edges
of this little mud pan here
[Music]
and maneuvering very quickly so it's two
kitchen spray but also when something
small like this you don't want to stand
still for too long because you yourself
could become prey
[Music]
now while we're watching him I'm keeping
an eye out for evidence in this mud of a
sand beetle larvae we were talking
several weeks ago about a friend of mine
that was busy with assessments for
tracking sign on a senior-level
and one of the amazing photos that he
sent me during his practice and then I
was practicing with him was of sand
beetle larvae and I am now super keen to
try and show it to you so that if you
want we can come up here to the screen
so that mud that that three-banded
clubber was just banding around in this
is what the sand beetle larva would look
like this is the type of track I'm sorry
about that the type of track that it
would make oh and that reminds me while
we're busy with this I found out the
answer to our insect question from
yesterday so let me find that photo for
you for anyone that wasn't watching so I
went back home and I asked James I asked
a couple of guys what do we think this
is do we think it's you know a beetle do
we think it's a grasshopper or a clicker
in Stara sort of in stars are the
maturity level and they molt and they
look different throughout their and
stars constantly and then I send it
through to a very good friend of mine
who works in the timber body here's the
just busy focusing for you can we all
see that there and it turns out it's a
young armored ground cricket so I'm not
quite sure if we shown the armored
ground cricket cricket on the show
before they're a lot bigger than this
this little guy is probably the size of
your pinky nail
maybe a little bit smaller and they get
very gray and they eat each other and
they're everywhere so this is a young
version of that and it was new for me
it's new for a lot of the people that
I've talked to so thank you so much
James Stan for that wonderful answer and
always always being able to answer every
question that I asked
and so now I'm interested to see how
many more we can find another friend of
mine that works in Mozambique was saying
he sees these young armoured ground
crickets sort of lit in little swarms
but this has been my first season that
I've seen them so we'll have to keep our
eye out for them
we've got a fish Eagle sub that's coming
in to land
beautiful one of our resident fish
eagles we've got a pair that lives here
at chitwa chitwa dam flew off over our
heads earlier I was hoping that it would
go on a little fishing expedition but it
seems to have not found anything to eat
all right so we've done some excellent
birding and we've had some good hippo
audio but I think now that the clouds
have really come through and the sun's
gone away a little bit and starting to
cool off I think let's go on a little
bubble and see what we can find around
the dam and farther into chitwa chitwa
property
[Music]
okay let's be on our way go across the
dam wall have a look-see down maybe we
get lucky maybe little vasana
is down there
so while we're busy looking let's head
on over to a Tristan and see what he has
found for us this afternoon
well I did have some dwarf Mongoose but
they've left us for dead they've left us
all by ourselves unfortunately so there
was a small little grouping of them that
we're all kind of scuttling about on the
spoiler Nova treats my right but they've
decided that this is not where they want
to be they've decided that they're going
to go and run into the grass get away
from me and not be visible at all
actually there's one that's decided to
show itself so I love these little guys
I can always spend quite some time with
them I'd as I drive along and kind of
see them scuttling about it's always
worth just stopping and having a little
look around and seeing what they busy
with they generally are up to something
enough to no good they chasing little
things or digging playing with one
another and I mean Noel had that crazy
interaction the other day with the black
mamba where they got that snake up into
the tree and they walk during away and
really kind of alarm calling and making
quite a bit of noise so there are fun
species to follow around the problem is
that some of them are a little bit more
shy than others and so some will duck
into grass like this and disappear and
others will sit around and you can
actually watch them so this Lots is not
the most friendly so I think we're going
to carry on and see if we can't find
some others that will at least show
themselves to us now I'll search before
Tandi has been slowly
well actually I puts it on pause for a
little bit because what we were doing is
we had a reports of an elephant boo
very close to where we were just now
when you last saw us and I went in that
direction but either VM and I are blind
or our elephant boo has grown ears like
Dumbo and flown away because there was
absolutely no sign of this elephant
where they said it was and so now I just
decided well because we were that side
and we were in the sort of central parts
that it would be nice to go and just
have it and also look around and see
what else was about so far but quiet
there's been the odd Impala lamb but not
very much else now Kirsty is telling me
that there is an elephant on the dam cap
I don't know if it can be the same
enough and maybe it is maybe it just
decided to run all the way to the dam
and beat us there so maybe we will
meander our way that side it's actually
not the worst idea then we can go up gar
recap line and we can check along maybe
higher Oh
Jahna road north-south those areas
incased undies been lurking in that
section so not the worst idea what we'll
do is we'll go through full amonst up
and then we'll take ingre alley which is
our little sneaky road that's not so
sneaky anymore it's now become a
full-grown Road Scott will be very happy
I remember when I was living in the UK
for a few months and it was just when
Scott and Brent had arrived and I
started watching because I knew both of
them and it was also nice just to watch
from you know but of home from when I
was outside of the country and I
remember them driving this particular
road and was just a little too track it
almost look like a sitings road now it's
a full-on proper kind of graded well
looked after well-maintained piece of
sort of land and it's easy to drive on
so Scott's going to love the fact that
this road is like that because I know he
used to like driving it quite a bit used
to be a firm favourite for of his
especially to find couldn't human
quarantine so I'm pretty sure he'll be
happy to be back and to be able to check
these areas again right
the good thing about this road is it's
got a number of little wallows edits and
now wallows are great in weather like
we've got today and the Sun isn't really
shining too much but it is quite humid
it's quite warm there's a few storm
clouds that are building and so it is
going to drive animals to start already
coming down for water early in the
afternoon and you'll find on a road like
this that's quite near a drainage line
lots of little wallows and puddles
it's great for small antelope species
and Yala dicus to invoke those kind of
things and that didn't turn attract some
of the Predators so hopefully we'll get
lucky on this road and while I kind of
negotiate it and see what I can find
let's go across to Noel and hopefully
she's got a bird and it's the one that
she's searching for
hi everyone so we were leaving the dam
and then we got to the edge here and we
had green-backed herons and pied
wagtails but then our huge croc that we
saw this morning and that big mama croc
started meandering around this fallen
over tree that's in the water I can just
see her under underneath sinks up and it
looks like she's looking for something
it's it's interesting she had her mouth
slightly open and she was manoeuvring
now I can see one of the hatchlings
where they normally are and she's
heading in that direction I just want to
keep an eye on her not quite sure it's
also possible it is in the water it's
also possible that it's not the mommy
croc that it's the other croc that's in
the dam
and it's also possible that maybe
there's some fish or something that's in
there that she's busy after all of this
is just conjecture just curious it's
just keeping an eye out and then just to
the or just going to leave her for a
second if we go just to the right there
we can see our hatchling and there's
that green bacteria but there's one of
the hatchlings I've still only seen the
one today and our green oh you can see -
thanks Sen there's a green back Herron
is making a run for it past
[Music]
it's amazing how they're in the same
spot always I would guesstimate that
they were born quite close to here
sometimes when they're born the mum will
put them in her mouth and and sort of
transport them to the area that she
wants that's also possible that that
happened and our yeah I think she's just
resting I think we got overly excited
with all of her movements and now I
think she's just resting our
green-backed Heron has gone up into this
dead tree towards the red-billed Buffalo
Weaver's nests there we go
this is one of my favorite Birds I don't
know why I just find them appealing
they're quite interesting when they're
hunt hunting Tristan had some really
great action last week with a with this
same Heron busy fishing away at the edge
here and so we've been waiting with
bated breath to see if if he does
anything watching getting bird action
and and sort of hunting action with
these guys is a little bit harder and it
sometimes takes a lot longer but we have
Brent with stalking cheetah so let's
head up to him because that hopefully
will turn into a bit more action than we
have right now
welcome back everyone the Musketeers are
on the move
Alice here we go I'm just gonna keep
quiet for a few seconds welcome everyone
welcome welcome we are with five male
cheetahs known as the Musketeers they
are busy slowly creeping up towards well
they got sidetracked by a little
argument amongst themselves
oh you silly cheaters you've just given
it away there's a bit of politics going
on amongst them but that little fight
and has caused the prey that there was
talking to spot them they were stalking
three topi and a single Thomson's
gazelle now they have been spotted so
the game is there are lots of animals
around here if they keep heading in the
direction and that they are now going
away from the taupe in the Thompson's
gazelle about seven or eight hundred
metres away is a herd of wildebeest but
let's just have a look there might still
know some of them have decided to flop
down so Oh flop that little argument
ruined the had not topi snorting and
charging towards them remember this is a
hundred percent live from the Maasai
Mara in Kenya we cannot predict what's
going to happen we can just try be in
the best possible spot the right time so
now what happen happens is that when
answer they spot something like a cheat
or a line they will move a little bit
closer and they will start snorting at
it to tell the other members of the herd
or even the other hand slopes close by
that there is danger about now there's a
howling gale of a Wednesday so the
cheetah probably gonna move
away from where those animals are and up
towards where this and vol the beasts
and zebra and some Thomson's gazelle and
I doubt that they're going to be able to
hear the smarting of the the taupe you
do to this very very strong wind and
Janice's it just loves these naughty
boys and there we go that up on the move
again
and they are heading in the right
direction towards a herd of wildebeest
small herd but and they will try a cart
a sub-adult or a youngster from that
herd
we're just gonna stay put where we are
for a little bit longer I just want to
see their body we won't be looking for
is their body language to change as soon
as they get closer to those valda beasts
there's some available cover for them as
well
which might make the stalk a little bit
easier they did catch a small antelope a
baby impala a bit earlier today but with
four five boys
that's not much food at all
Donna says this is so awesome indeed it
is isn't this incredible donor we are
bringing you cheetah
hunting alive well failed hunting but
still on the hands and I think we're
just gonna stick with them for a little
bit I'm gonna get a bit closer though
and just to make sure I can choose the
right direction that they're gonna go by
the way I forgot to say hello my name is
Brent and I've got jar on camera and
following of the musketeers on the hunt
okay so they're moving towards what we
call a leg a in East Africa like there's
this little line of trees you see yeah
it's most of the time it's a little dry
a dry creek but when it does rain it
does flow it does hold certain spots
will hold pools of water so it could be
a bit careful finding a spot to cross it
okay let's have a look where are those
cheater off - hold on now also one of
the things I've got it really take into
consideration now is where are the
cheats are going to go are they gonna
head towards the Valda beast which is
just up to my right so I'm just going to
stop quickly so you can have a look or
are they going to keep me heading due
north almost ah on top of the hill and
Aware's at the moment while the cheetah
move they might disturb something else
that gets them on the go they will chase
anything even a little hair that they
might disturb they might find a little
diptych hiding in these these thickets
or read back
so I'm just going to position myself yet
to see where they go to next the moment
they're doing what the cheetah do we're
just going to wipe the lens there is a
bit of rain so if you see that cough
don't worry you remember this is live
happening right this very second so we
have to deal with the elements the bumps
so it is quite exciting and quite unique
a little bit to the left still coming
from the top of the termite mound
and where are you just come out of it so
I can see we are now yeah I can see them
they're on top of the termite mound just
to the right of the gardenias if that
helps ah there we go
castor says what amazing landscape
indeed it is
now you can see some vultures just at
the top of screen that's where they were
where they killed the little antelope
earlier when it was a very slim pickings
for the vultures
I'm sure the vultures will be hoping
that these guys catch something a bit
bigger and leave some scraps for them
now as I say if you have any questions
just pop them on the feed below there's
one two three four it is five
now Heather wants to know if these
cheetah are related a few of them
probably are but it seems that they're
of different ages a little bit of
different ages so it's probable that not
all of them are alia related and you can
see the size difference in some of them
I do apologize about the noise but as I
said it's a howling gale arch here in
the Mara today according to what I was
reading at certain areas the wind is hit
80 kilometers an hour I wouldn't say
we're that bad we're probably at about
40 kilometres an hour here oh yeah
that's let's get a bit closer it doesn't
look like they're gonna head for those
valle de b's just yet but there are more
animals just up ahead on the next crest
now we're heading into a cheetah's
favorite time of the day to hunt they
won't hunt at any time of the day like
all big cats they're opportunists
but the crepuscular hours so the hours
just before sunset and just after sunset
and the hours just before sunrise and
just after sunrise are when they are the
most active in terms of hunting and also
the most successful
let's have a quick look what's up ahead
here
bouncy bouncy bouncy
now you will see a few other vehicles
around also enjoying these cheetah is a
strong possibility they're gonna head up
to the top of this crest and there's
some animals up there but there's some
beautiful scenes to be had before then
Matt is wondering will cheetah always
hunt upwind no Matt not always at the
moment they're actually walking across
the winter they're not walking upwind or
downwind Oh walking straight across it
and it is coming from the left and
blowing to the right you can see some
lovely skies as well this is Big Sky
Country the Masai Mara
now we've spent off probably close now
to nine hours with them today
Oh have you finally spotted the Valle de
beast in the distance and thus all the
beasts are running but not from the
cheetah they're just running around
Lincoln is wondering how many times do
their hunt in a day well Lincoln it is
completely dependent on what they catch
if they catch something small they can
hand multiple times a day
if they catch something big and it
doesn't get stolen by lions or hyenas
they'll only hide once every two days so
it all just depends on what they catch
now this is when this is the biggest
known a coalition of male cheetah nadine
says Wow Wow Wow
wild cheetah love those cats there are
incredible cats and unfortunately it
seems like the wildebeest that were
behind us have taken off and some of the
cats have decided to be a little bit
lazy but these two and you can see there
are quite hungry are still on the move
maybe would like to know what is that
larger size of prey they can take down
well because there's five of them it
enables them to take down much larger
prey than a single cheetah even to
cheetah so we've seen them take down
adult coax hartebeest which can weigh
close on 200 kilograms so and they are
able to take down a very big animals
where they themselves probably weigh
around 60 kilograms each between 60 and
70 kilograms probably be a bit rude to
ask them to jump on a scale Costa V is
wondering which predator to cheetah most
often have to defend themselves against
probably hyenas they have the most
interactions with and when the hyenas
still there their kills and they will
try to defend against hyenas however if
lions arrive but the cheetah even five
of them is no match for a single lioness
who can weigh up to about 120 kilograms
so they'd make their escape using their
incredible speed
man is wondering are they still
genetically in danger well yes and no
they've got very very little genetic
variation in there in all in the whole
population of cheetah worldwide and this
came due to a die-off about ten thousand
years ago during the last ice age where
the surviving cheetah populations were
separated and the cheetah that were left
on the wrong side of the ice basically
all died and leaving a very very small
portion of cheetah and that survived
that that genetic bottleneck because of
the ice age and down in Africa and Asia
so the cheetah originally stems from the
Americas feeds rubbish that was trying
to escape my car and the Cheetahs
closest relative is actually a puma or
mountain lion and a Jaguar mundi which
are both American cats and so it isn't
actually that closely related to any of
the African cats we've got some animals
after head there so I'm just gonna shoot
up ahead again now the reason I try to
stay up ahead of the cheetah far away
from them when they're on the hunt is so
that we don't interfere in the hunt so
we're trying to observe nature not
change the outcome either in the
Predators favor all the praise favor so
we're gonna go up ahead
we got zebra and wildebeest up on top of
this Ridge there's still quite a long
way they might just decide no they're
tired and sleep before they get there
and try again in the morning you can
never tell that's why we here alive
following them for hours upon hours
every day
not a bad way to spend a Sunday there so
we've got quite a few different species
happy had looks like we had some Valle
de beast zebra Thompson's gazelles maybe
a topi or two but you can see it's very
very open in front of me they're gonna
have trouble getting close but that's
where the incredible speed comes in and
what they'll be do is they'll be
watching even from a distance all these
different herds and what they're gonna
try to do is pick an individual that's
that's got a limp or just something that
often you can't see with the human eye
that they'll pick up that it's a little
bit lame or anything like that now as
they get closer we should see their
behavior changing a little bit
and we'll know when they're about to
charge off
now being mailed cheaters they can't
risk a good scent mark I think they
might mark their territory mark their
territory under those bushes Joshua is
wondering what these cheats to be able
to take down a baby giraffe yes a
coalition of five males would definitely
be able to take down a baby giraffe here
we go now when they go stop and sniff
their that's like a the classified ads
in a newspaper who's been there who's
how long have they been gone for all
sorts of stuff like that that they can
smell from the urine of other cheetah
now in this area it's mostly them
because they've been scent marking
around here prodigiously over the last
few months and they will continue to
send mark so if any other male cheetah
happened to come into the area they
would immediately know that it was
already occupied and even more security
so I have five individuals so you try
get out of there as quickly as possible
now you can see quite a lot of
wildebeest in the distance who would
like to note with the coalition split if
food was scarce like large lion prides
to you it is possible but I think the
more likely is that popular other the
coalition will split if it comes down to
too much pressure with the mating and
it's going to be very interesting to see
as they get older and they start
encountering females with Easter's who
are in Easter's weather some of the
subordinate males in the coalition are
going to be happy with only one or two
of the male's doing the mating or are
they going to break away and form their
own smaller coalition where they might
get more mating opportunities
well it looks like they're actually
gonna take a little break have a little
snooze case yawns wondering what is
their favorite food
Keshawn whatever food they can catch a
lot of these animals are not fatty
meters meat and they needed to survive
so it's generally a survival thing so
that is what they will eat that is their
favorite food
well well it looks like as I said
they're gonna have a little rest but
don't worry I'm gonna be with these
cheetah so if they do start hunting
again keep a lookout for that go live
notification and jar and I will be there
to bring you right to the action live
from Kenya so goodbye for now
well it looks like the boys are going to
have a break before continuing on we're
gonna stay with them a little bit longer
so we're still quite far from camp
probably about 40 kilometers or so 25
kilometers or so 40 kilometers would be
on as the crow flies home almost but it
said we're probably going to stay with
him for another 10 or 15 minutes before
we just have to start making our way
back towards Salle's but in the meantime
let's go across to Tristan back in South
Africa
well that was exciting to see the is to
go about this stalking procedure and
hopefully they'll continue to do so
while brent is out and about with him
but as you can see we've had a bit of
luck of our own and we found a very
gentle giant who is absolutely loving
these green bushes that are around the
support Waller
there's green grass that's growing out
of the mud and he is tucking into it as
much as possible so he's walking around
and just literally eating grass all
around the pan itself and he's the most
relaxed individual he's really hasn't
been worried about us at all and of
course now that you're back with us he
would start moving we've been sitting
for him with him for about the last I
would say 15 minutes and he hasn't moved
and one of a sudden nice decided that
this grass is no longer good and he's
going to meander his way a bit further
northwards as the Sun comes up maybe
he's realized with the Sun coming out
it's time to find a more shady section
in what he's in at the moment but he
really is the most relaxed individual he
hasn't at any stage even for one second
looked at us approached us given us any
nonsense whatsoever and so it's quite
wonderful to spend time with an
individual like this we've just been
sitting under the shade tree and
watching him go about his business has
been absolutely wonderful but he is
behind us and feeding so I'm gonna just
quickly turn around and make sure that
we can actually see him and not just
stare at me because well the elephant is
far prettier than what I am that's for
sure
now I believe a lot of you are marveling
at his size and very happy to see an
elephant now he's not the biggest
elephant that we get archery in fact
he's a young bull stall so I would say
that this elephant is probably maybe
within the 20s that's what I would put
him at I don't think he's much older
than that I think he's in a situation
where he's still going to grow quite
some well quite a lot more he's going to
be substantially bigger than what he is
now the thing about him is is that he's
got quite nice
tusks already which is very cool to see
so it's nice to see that in the Kruger
system we're starting to get more and
more of these elephant bulls that have
these really nice big tusks again and
that gene seems to be coming back into
sort of the area and we're starting to
see a lot more of these individuals
coming out of this particular section
and so that's always wonderful and I'm
just trying to get ourselves into a
situation where we're not being blinded
by the Sun and vm's not being blinded by
the Sun this particular elephant is
moving straight towards Gauri damn or
zoom atom and so I'm pretty sure if we
just stay with him for a little bit we
will get him feeding at some point now
I'm gonna probably stop here oh that's
very casual of you this has got its foot
resting sorry of you my nowhere that's a
bit of an angle at the moment I
apologize but we'll sort that out fairly
quickly
scenic yes most suits in the elephants
will feed off plants that grow in water
they feed off a lot of different reeds
so particularly things like papyrus if
you go down onto the sabbia River system
which is a river that flows all the time
you'll find lots and lots of reeds on
the banks there that are in the water
itself and they'll pull those out if you
go into the aqua vengo Delta and that
Wicklund area chobe area you'll find
that they feed extensively on vegetation
that is growing some of the lilies and
they'll feed off like I say some of the
reeds that grow in there and here in the
sabi sands not as much I mean they will
feed of lilies in the sabi sands a
little bit and then sometimes our feet
of what's called jungle rice now jungle
rice is a type of grass that grows just
around the fringes of these small mud
wallows and sometimes even in the water
a little bit so yes they do feed off
vegetation that grows inside water they
do love it particularly when they get a
little
older and the reason why when they're
but always because their teeth are
wearing and it becomes much harder to be
able to eat these brace of hard woody
plants that we see in places like this
and on the crest areas and so they go
towards water where those plants are
full of moisture and they tend to have a
lot more water content and therefore
tend to be a lot softer and easier for
them to manage and to be able to digest
and get some sort of nutrients out of it
so you see a lot of older elephants
going into those sections right well we
being left behind so while I'm yakking
let's try and carry on driving a little
bit just to keep up with our Ellie as he
walks slowly northwards you saw just now
that he had his trunk up for a little
bit so you just popped his trunk up as
though he was smelling something so I
wonder if he's not picking up the other
elephant that was at Gauri dam before
I'm not sure if this is the same
elephants I don't think so because his
general direction is going north back
towards the dam and if it was the same
elephant I don't think we'll have a
situation where he's going to go back to
the same place he's just come from if he
was feeding like this so while I try and
catch up and get into a better area and
get alongside him once again let's go
across to Noel who seems to be keeping
me and his found a self an elephant of
her own
Tristan of course I'm copying you my
dream is to be you I cry every night
when I go home and I'm not you and it's
amazing as you are Shay my friend yes I
am God a little bit beautiful big big
beautiful male elephant that has come up
towards twin dams so we were with that
wonderful Gleevec Terran waiting for it
to hunt and then we got an update that
husana is being chased out of little
gallery by some baboons towards twindom
so we're parking off at twin dams to see
if we can find them there's no visual on
him at the moment so we're going to
enjoy our male elephant who's been very
carefully moving branches aside to get
to the green green green grass that you
can just see him playing with at the
bottom here getting all of the soil off
and then putting it in his mouth very
tasty very nutritious grass growing on
the side of a termite mound termite
mounds producing nutrient pools that
allows for a lot of palatable a lot of
tasty grasses to grow
and never tire of viewing the skin of
these elephants sorry Alice I heard the
question but I didn't hear the viewer so
I believe the question is where do
elephants get their their salt intake
from they get it from big sorry guys I'm
just having trouble hearing who the
viewer is I'm so sorry please excuse me
they get it from soil that they will
ingest they get it from some of the the
the water has a lot of sort of calcium
things in it and then the vegetation
that they eat as well will give those
those intakes but what they're very good
at doing is they're very good at
smelling mineral deposits in the ground
then getting down on their wrists and
and Tuscon up the soil and then eating
physically eating the soil and what's
called geo Fei Jie all right he headed
towards the dead and I'm hoping he's
going to play around in the water
but a little bit of an incline please
excuse me as I generally reverse I don't
want to lose Seb off the back that would
be bad
this is gonna be quite nice with them
coming around the corner here hello
buddy are you today you can see just how
big he actually is compared to those
trees around us he's going to feed over
here a little bit as well
I'm just going to angle our vehicle a
little bit differently
just to keep him in view for you all
come around the corner a little bit see
what his space bullet-like
been getting towards the damn than
anything I have to do
he's already been to some water so he
may choose not to go at all
he's listening to us and watching us
down the side of his body there but on a
warm sort of humid day like today even
though he's already been towards water
he may decide to do it again he is now
stopping and just watching us and
keeping keeping an eye out
slight bit of displacement behavior
there but in general quite relaxed so
we're gonna move around just over to the
side here and then catch another visual
with him and we're still peepers open
form asana unfortunately I think because
he was so agitated by those baboons that
were chasing him he moved away quite
quickly and gave the guy's a little bit
of the slip but as said was saying to me
now twin dams used to be a big area for
husana when he was a youngster so
because he's not old old yet he's still
a little bit done he does like to come
back here and investigate his area and
there's a few trees that Herbie's also
showed me that herbie says are some of
his favorites
my buddy sorry I'm a boy I'll sit back
here so that's right there is that
elephant just saying listen I know
you're here I would like more space than
you've given me I've given him about 80
meters but he just needs a little bit
more so that's fine we'll let him have
his space we'll let him come around and
then we'll go sit on the dam wall and
then he'll have lots of space every
every animals personal bubble is is
different and few guys he is a big
beautiful boy
definitely gorgeous and very nice very
thick tush not super long but very even
he's got some good genes in him
all right
you can actually see him I know we
passed by this area quite a bit on the
eastern side of twin dams here but I
mean you can see his size in terms of
that jackal berry on his right snazzy
you've heard that elephants enjoy music
and is this true sadly I actually
couldn't tell you and I've never been in
a scenario where I've had music playing
with elephants around I would assume
that has something to do with the
vibrations and that's what they might
enjoy I'm wondering if maybe that's the
context that came from is possibly
captive elephants and maybe something
with the music is soothing for them
because they are in captivity instead of
being out the wild that would be where I
would go with that I do know when I'm
self driving myself through Kruger
National Park that I when I come up to a
herd of elephants I do turn my music in
my car off if I haven't seen anything
just because they hear so well I don't
want to do anything to disturb them I
just want to watch them and also Bush
sounds are amazing when you're sitting
still but it's an interesting thought I
would I would wonder if the type of
music would be the soothing part as
opposed to all music in general
so that breaking branch sound that we
heard just now when you're tracking
elephant sometimes in a vehicle
sometimes I put to pee what you're doing
if you can't see them if it's a thick
area that's the sound that you're
listening for that breaking branches on
it's a very specific type of sound do
noting that an elephant is is present
there you can see nicely the angle that
he's at that back flap to his ear is
hanging very low there at the top of the
ear you can not age precisely but you
can say that an elephant is much older
when that flap is is very long and
behind when he turns his head again just
now we should get a better view there we
go
that flap there so not my secret wish in
my head is we sit here with this big
beautiful male elephant does that
hasanah just comes walking up and says
how do you do but he's being actually
cheeky I still have not seen husana yet
so he needs to show himself at some
point now notice how meticulous he is
towards the end of his trunk there and
actually picking what leaves he wants
it's not just any leaf he's smelling and
then deciding these are the leaves that
I feel like eating there it goes
he's calculated that now sometimes when
he's feeding the way this meeting you
see that he can get his trunk up there
but sometimes they'll stand up and and
elongate their body to get up a little
bit higher while we're busy watching our
male elephant and waiting for husana to
magically appear Tristan has his own
elephants and I think he's getting a
little bit jealous and wants to copycat
us now so let's head back towards him so
that he feels better about himself can't
be copying when you find it first
unfortunately so we'll just claim the
title for today and like I say if it's
we find the sighting first thing well
unfortunately it can never be copying
our elephant was busy feeding along
before Noelle's elephant was I think who
knows depends on which one was older
actually as to which one was first but
either way it doesn't matter still nice
to have Elly's with both vehicles there
was a long period of time where we've
had no elephants whatsoever between any
of us and so to have a few bulls around
and the odd heard lately has been
absolutely wonderful I've thoroughly
enjoyed having these guys all over the
place now it seems to be an interesting
situation this afternoon because now all
sitting with a male elephant I'm sitting
with the male elephant she's waiting for
her sonnets who potentially magically
appear at twin dams and I'm waiting for
10 garnets who magically appear
somewhere on cheetah cut line because
both lipids on mobile both lipids
general direction is towards outside but
both of them are not here yet so
hopefully at some point we're gonna get
lucky with one of the lipids crossing
over ting ganas in tortured and
apparently is moving in this general
vicinity so it's a weird sort of twist
of fate that both of us are in a similar
position and kind of waiting on
something to happen with regards to our
spotty cats but hopefully like I say one
of them I think the odds probably got a
lot more opportunity than what I do and
ting gana is still very far from the
edge of the cheetah cap line he's on the
other side of tortured camp stall so
he's moving but at this stage still a
long way out but it is the most
beautiful scene just sitting with this
bull I've thoroughly enjoyed sitting
here it's been quiet there's
it's not too hot the Sun isn't art these
these beautiful kind of clouds that are
spread across the sky they've got green
grass which is just so pleasant on the
eye after months of drab Brown sort of
dead voltage and so to have this and
with this peaceful bull elephant as he
munches away it's been absolutely
wonderful now in between us enjoying our
bull elephant and watching him go about
his business VM and I have been
discussing all mannerisms of interesting
things and maybe you guys can help us
out and see what you guys think we were
we were talking about if it was possible
would you have a situation where you
could have miniature elephants that were
the size of a dog and then would all the
other animals if they were that size
would they be scaled down in the same
way and that there could be miniature
safari parks do you think it would work
and then we got onto the conversation of
domestic cats being a big problem for a
safari park of that size because they
would just cause havoc because vm loves
cats vm answer cats at home and we're
talking about a domestic cat getting
into a miniature safari park would be a
nightmare but it would be quite fun I
think to have imagined having a little
baby elephant walking around all over
the place
and moving around he says that would be
her dream kirsty loves anything that's a
little and anything that has big eyes
well because that's very similar to
Kirsty herself she's a little on the
smaller side and has big eyes herself
and so she loves Bush babies but she
reckons that Safari Park would be the
best idea for little animals though but
like we were saying just now a VM says
to me he reckons that's that's a
elephant should be about this size and
should still have tusks when it gets
fully grown so they must be touched
there and then we just scale everything
according to this so if an elephant was
the size unfortunately I think a bush
baby would be almost microscopic and it
would be very difficult to have so I'm
afraid that's probably not going to work
for Kirsty but maybe we can just leave
bush babies at the real size and Christy
will enjoy that although I feel like
bush babies would dominate everybody if
they were that size but the Lions the
Lions that we were saying that should
have no tails
the vegetarian lines yes we wanted to
discuss this to Sevilla and I discussed
whether or not lions would be quite
interesting if they were demilitarized
so basically if they had no claws and
they had molars instead of canines and
these con Nationals that they have in
their mouths and so we thought well if
we replaced them with molars and they
ate vegetation with this we'll be as
hardcore with glands be just fluffy
animals and vien says to me no everybody
would love that because the line who
doesn't want to hug a lion
lions are huggable creatures and
everybody wants to hug one so without
those sharp claws and teeth then they
wouldn't really be able to hurt us and
we could hug line so that's what VM
reckons and he reckons that if that were
the case that line should be the same
size as what they are now and he reckons
that they would look quite hardcore
without a tail now of course I've seen
female lines without a tail but we were
talking about male lines with male lines
look better with our tails or worse with
that with two would they're better with
with tails should I say and then we got
into the subject of whether leopard
would look better with the tail or
without a tail so it's been an
interesting conversation this afternoon
VM and I have really gone through a lot
of interesting topics and we're solving
the world's problems one by one what do
you think they're mouthing sir in some
stage all of these things you never know
might be possible which would be a sad
day actually in all seriousness the way
people do miss around with genetics and
and these kind of things it would be
very sad if we got to a situation where
we had miniature versions of all these
animals because I think it would just
detract completely from the magnificence
of an animal like this but I say we have
giggled and laughed about it and VM
always comes up with the best
conversations I love being on camera
with well being on a vehicle with VM
because he really does come up with the
most interesting thoughts and I'd never
really thought about a mole of fooled
line before but now that I have thought
about here what VM is saying and I like
his idea now you can see our label is
just going to drift and coast right past
us he's now that he's broken through
this little thicket and onto this fire
break he's sniffing around and he's
looking for little growths of certain
types of trees so maybe some of the
aromatics maybe any small little
occasions that might have grown during
this little period of rain and and you
can see the grass itself is still too
short since they didn't find anything
while he was sniffing and so he's going
to just carry on and he's gonna try
find the next thicket where they will be
vegetation that he can feed off so he's
not actually going up towards the
waterhole anymore so maybe it is the
same elephant I'm not 100% sure but
interesting to watch their behavior you
would think that even though he's been
feeding off grasses everywhere else that
as soon as he came out since the open
you would carry on feeding off grass
which you can see is literally just
crossed straight over the road and now
he's going towards another bush that he
can then begin to feed off him and find
food in so it's amazing just to watch
him as he goes along and he's had a
really nice for a variety of food I've
seen him eating grass then he was onto a
knob thorn for a bit then he went on to
a bush willow at terminalia now he's
onto a buffalo thorn so he's having a
proper mixed salad this afternoon and
elephants will do this they don't always
feed off the same plant they're not like
something like a giraffe that will try
and target occasions for long periods of
time elephants will go to various
species and try and get nutrients out of
different plants and try and mix up
their diet as much as possible but he is
going to go into a rather dense thick
area now and I really don't crashing
after him he's been so obliging and so
nice to us this afternoon already and
we've had such a long period with him
that I think I'm gonna let him go and
carry on on his own accord and watch him
just drift off into the distance right
now I believe Jamie Patterson who's in
the Masai Mara and is driving around
he's searching for a mysterious animal
and I wonder what it could be
so do i I really wonder what it could be
I am so frustrated in a way and so
intrigued I have absolutely no idea what
Craig and I just saw it
Dover out of a tree dived out of a tree
it looked it was big it was black in
color does about the size of a female
baboon but with a long tail but pitch
black and a brand like a monkey but from
only from what little I could see
there's no others so a monkey species
that isn't social no it would have gone
it would have sought refuge in a tree
it's not a bush baby it's not a menace
to push baby because the tail wasn't
fluffy enough it had a long tail a long
sort of almost vervet monkey ish tail I
think it was so brief and so quick and
I'm utterly kun I I'm bemused I have no
idea what it was I have no idea what it
could be and I have no idea where it
went I can't work this one out it's not
often we see something that we go what
on earth is that
why out of the tree prenez general I
confess I didn't see the size of its
feet listen Craig sword - Craig you
sword - no don't do that Craig was the
one who spotted it there's a crack
gremlins General says Big Foot so I
didn't see the size of its feet but
possibly but where's God
I've been searched this has been a half
an hour process I have been in and out
of the strange line the last time I saw
it was there you see if it's gone to
ground then it would be something along
along the lines of a cat I thought about
a melanistic serval but its tail was I
think too long and then I thought maybe
a massive melanistic Genet its tail
didn't look right I have never been so
confused in my entire life and what's
even more confusing is this - hyena that
are hanging out in here somewhere and
they look completely disinterested
so wherever drowned - if it ran it
didn't run past them it's just check
maybe it did go to ground and moved fast
it moved so quickly
hey all these vehicles are stopping
asking me what I've seen and I'm good
and I don't know I don't know what I've
seen I really feel like I'm losing my
mind but I know I saw it
species of monkey
it was pitch black almost completely
pitch black know you've seen others
guinea fowl here so it didn't come the
swirl they would have got a fright the
speed that it was moving they would have
they would have startled and what's
weirder is that the birds were alarm
calling at us
the shrikes were alarm calling at it
which makes you think capped will Genet
something like that it was in a tree I'm
so confused and I'm so gonna get us
stuck in my desperation to figure this
one out
[Music]
I am NOT gonna sleep tonight now he's
wondering what I'm looking at
I'd better go and tell him paddy is
telling Craig to help me Craig and I was
so confused and I was concentrating so
hard on the terrain I'd better go tell
these people that I haven't found
anything I was concentrating so hard on
the terrain should I bury Seng in his
drive up to a guide and he asked you
what you've seen and you say I don't
know none of us know the cetys on the
back with me he doesn't know either we
are all very confused and look I think
if we'd had a good look at it we'd be
able to tell you but it was running it
was running away from us so quickly
tiny melanistic leopard No
I don't know I wish I had an answer for
you I wish I had an answer for me we'll
never see it again and we'll never know
while Never Say Never but chances are
better go tell the sky because noise
he's late thinking I found a leopard for
him
what am I gonna say